You were invited to a
huge celebrity wedding.
I know.
And you don't know why.
I do know why.
I was, I think I was just so flattered
and excited and honored,
that it kind of didn't make sense.
Well, tell us, tell the story.
All right.
And start at the beginning
where you're in your
bed, uh, corn crib, whatever.
Ah, see, you were so close.
Ah, it was close.
[Jack] Honestly.
You were in your normal bed.
Thank you.
Oh, right.
That a person in the
21st century would have.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
And you've got the covers pulled up,
and you are waking up.
Yes.
[Conan] Outside, cock-a-doodle-doo!
Oh, come on, come on.
There it is.
Wait a minute. That's not.
A lot of people have chickens now.
Really?
[Conan] And roosters. Yes they do!
No.
Let's take a poll. I don't.
I don't.
I don't. I guess I win.
Okay.
That's my point. My point is we don't,
but we are in a bubble.
Most people out there have chickens.
But you specifically
Cock-a-doodle-doo! And you wake up
Eat my slop.
(laughter)
Thank you! Eat your slop.
Then it's out to the north
40 and you get to work.
(Jack groans)
No, anyway, please tell us how you,
[Jack] I'll walk you through it, yeah.
Tell us about the celebrity wedding.
[Jack] Okay.
'Cause this is a big one.
Okay. So, here's how it all began.
The year was 2009.
(laughter)
"30 Rock" was going.
Alec Baldwin was hosting
SNL on February 14th, 2009.
The musical guest were the Jonas Brothers.
Oh, for God's sake. Oh, okay.
I see where you're
going now. For a minute,
Oh.
I didn't know where this was all going.
You were already fresh,
let him tell the story!
Yeah, You told him to take it
through from beginning to end.
Well, I thought he was gonna,
it's like he was testifying
and he was giving dates
And I got nervous.
No, I wanna hear the story.
All right, I don't wanna ruin it,
'cause I think this will be good.
Take us from the beginning and go.
(snorts)
I literally was.
I know, I know, I apologize.
He's doing the thing you asked.
[Conan] I apologize.
And you stopped him to tell
him to do the thing you asked.
Well, he started giving dates.
I don't want dates. But anyway, go ahead.
You do dates all the time.
Please.
Okay, I'm sorry.
Ugh. So anyways.
The musical guest were the Jonas Brothers,
Alec had me come on and do a little cameo
during his opening monologues.
So, of course I was thrilled to do that.
I was like, "Absolutely."
But during the course of the rehearsals
and the performances and stuff,
you know, just hanging out,
I got to know the Jonas Brothers.
Delightful individuals, all three of 'em.
And so that was in 2009,
and like, they were babies back then.
And so it's not like I was like,
"Hey, let's exchange information
and be friends forever."
But during the course of
years, our paths crossed again.
I saw them at a different SNL
when Tracy Morgan was hosting,
I was staying in a hotel in Toronto
that Nick Jonas happened to be at.
And then here in Los
Angeles, I'm neighbors with
a very talented actor named Glen Powell.
Ahh!
He was just in the "Top Gun" movie.
[Matt] Oh, yeah.
Oh, he's the best.
So many attractive men in this story.
So
[Sona] Yeah.
So, Glen and Nick Jonas
had worked together on
"Scream Queens," which I
think was either Fox or FX.
Yeah.
And so Glen is just such a lovely host.
He would have game nights, movie nights,
you know, just, hangout nights.
And so, Nick Jonas would
come to those parties.
I was their neighbor,
so I would come over.
Again, I'm a thousand years
older than any of these children
so I'd be like, "Quiet down, now."
(laughter)
And just as a side note,
Nick Jonas happens to be
a big fan of the movie,
"They Came Together," that I was in.
I mean, I have to admit, I
haven't even seen the movie.
But, he was such a big fan,
Glen would invite me over,
and then Nick would ask
me all these questions
about the movie that I simply
didn't have the answers to.
(Matt and Sona laughing)
So, I'm gonna catch us up.
[Matt] Oh, no.
You became tight with some
of the Jonas Brothers.
Am I taking too long?
A little bit.
No!
[Conan] I'm sorry.
No! Stop it.
I'm sorry, I was trying to get us,
uh, down the road a little bit.
No, no, no, no. I wanna hear more about
Glen Powell and stuff, too.
Let's just, stop butting in!
[Matt] (groans) Let the
man go on his journey.
But you asked me the question!
Yeah, sorry. We're sorry about him.
Yeah, we're sorry.
We only have so much tape in the machine.
[Sona] Stop. There is no tape.
Then you stop talking. Let me talk.
This is the worst day of my life.
(everyone laughing)
Okay. So, at this time,
Nick Jonas is dating Priyanka.
Ohh.
Priyanka Chopra.
Lovely, very talented actress.
And so, Nick would have these
fun activities with Priyanka,
but want to introduce some of
his friends to her, so like,
we went on a beautiful yacht
ride over Memorial Day weekend.
Ohh.
Just the three of you?
(Jack laughs)
No. No. It was Glen Powell,
you know, that whole crowd again.
Oh my god, fun.
You were on a yacht with Nick
Jonas and Priyanka Chopra?
Yeah.
You on a yacht, it's
just fantastic. This is,
Are you making fun of me?
I'm not making fun of
you. I think the idea of
me on a yacht is absurd.
I've never been on a yacht.
I mean, there's a great
many things in my life
that I'm like, "This is crazy."
[Conan] Right.
The Mariah Carey video,
getting eventually invited
to Nick and Priyanka's wedding.
Okay, well, you jumped to that.
[Jack] In India.
Stop it!
In India?
In India.
Ohh!
This is the thing I was
trying to get you to.
What?
[Conan] Some 40 minutes ago.
[Sona] Oh god.
No, no, no, it's just,
You're like,
No it's just, it's his podcast.
He's yammering on all this time
and then he gets mad
when somebody else talks.
Oh! Snap!
Wow, finally.
I'm sorry. I'm just saying it like it is.
[Sona] Yeah.
Okay. So.
(jack laughs)
Tell the story of you getting
invited to a wedding in India.
Not any wedding. Nick
Jonas, Priyanka Chopra
This is amazing.
We just heard that.
No, no, but now I wanna
hear about the wedding.
Okay. So the here's the thing.
That's the, I mean, this is a great story
but let's really get to the meat of it.
So I get invited to this wedding in India.
Have I ever been to India?
No. I don't even know.
Did you think it was
Indiana at first? Be honest.
Can you leave the room
(laughter)
Eduardo Let's cut his
mic. Let's cut his mic.
Oh, they've cut my mic.
Cut his vocal cords. (chuckles)
Okay. So you get invited. Go.
I'm sorry. I swear to God.
I'll shut up until we get
through the wedding. Go.
So I was so honored.
It was, it was bonkers.
I was like, "Yes. If
you're being serious. Yes."
And so I had, you know, a mutual friend
help me figure out how
to book that flight.
Now, have you ever been
to an Indian wedding?
I have not.
[Sona] No.
If you ever get invited to
an Indian wedding, say yes.
Isn't it days long?
It's a week long and it's amazing.
Ah. Fun.
It's like, there's so
many different events and
there's so many different wardrobe changes
like it's bonkers and it is fun
and it's just beautiful and musical
and like colors everywhere. It
was really, really fantastic.
So you flew all the way to India.
I flew to India.
But which city?
Uh Jaipur.
Jaipur.
[Sona] Jaipur!
Sona and I have been to Jaipur.
We have!
It was beautiful and,
and it was so fun and
it was like nothing I had ever,
it was like a Royal wedding, I guess.
I'd never been to one, but it was wild.
And like, I'm still friends
with all of Priyanka's cousins
and you know, I know all
the North Carolina family
on the Jonas side. It was
fun! It was really great.
So you were there for several days.
Yeah.
And you have to wear, you
wear special costumes, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
And like within a day you have to like
change over and stuff.
I'll send you pictures.
Did you, can I ask you a question?
This is a little, did
you pay for the costumes?
Oh yeah.
You did.
Yes, sir.
Because I know that you
are somewhat frugal.
Is that fair to say?
I guess. Where is this going?
No, I just wondering if you
thought it was an imposition,
Did I make homemade clothes for this?
(laughter)
If there's a way you,
do you know what I mean?
You are a frugal man.
When they said to you,
"You're gonna have to buy six outfits
and have them made for you,"
There was no hesitation at all?
No. And here's what else.
I did book my flight there with miles.
Oh.
And so I only paid $300 to get over there,
like in business class.
[Sona] Ooh!
I love that I whisper in
front of a microphone.
You whispered into a
microphone. No one can know.
Do they tell you what kind of clothes
you'll need for each event?
Yes. They were very, very
helpful for all of this.
So they actually hooked
us up with a company
that specializes in the clothes that
you'd wear for the certain ceremonies.
Yeah.
And you know, each one
had different meanings and
it was like nothing else I had ever seen.
And they made it very user friendly
and welcoming and it was awesome.
Now I have to call these people and say,
"Hey I talked about y'all's wedding."
Yeah.
Oh, it's fine. You said only nice things.
It's not like you said
anything untoward and
Untoward.
Well, I, I think he
acquitted himself well.
Oh, I think it's a rave review.
Yeah. Was a rave review
of a beautiful wedding.
It was, it was like nothing I had
ever, ever, ever experienced before.